OK 我覺得今天講幾個事情
就是那個首先週末的時候發生了
有一些GeoPolitical的這個新的變化
就是伊朗一環想談 一環不想談
然後我說一下
就是上兩週的市場整體的flow
然後我個人感覺這些政治上的新聞
或者是這個伊朗的這個戰爭的問題
對整個市場的影響
至少在本週會脫明
就是市場不太會特別關心這個東西
因為新一輪談判其實在那個巴基斯坦
好像是週四啊週三
週三又Vance要跟他們再談一次
但是我覺得本週基本上
市場還是會相對來說比較脫明一點
至三週我認為叫systematic buying
就是系統性的買入
其實是這個整個推動市場最主要原因
這個系統性買入
你就可以把它搶成是一種燃料
然後這個燃料一共買了
這個CTA56個別臉數據不是很多
主要是講美國的吧
然後整個Globo
上一週是沒錯
就是說整個Globo在過去兩週裡面
買了135個別臉
大概是這個規模
上一週好像是買了80個別臉
然後這個是一方面是CTA買
第二方面是PremBook在那裡
PremBook在那裡Shot Cover
把那個做空放頭在那裡
那裡相當於是頻掉
所以我個人感覺
這座整個買盤的力量
至少要延續到這週結束
所以這週結束以後
市場就是恢復到一個就休密
你最終業績怎麼樣
然後你最終這個
你不是談判嗎
然後你談判最後海峽會不會打開
在這一週影響不是很大
但是下一兩週開始就是要回到
看公司業界
然後回到看那個AI真正的需求
到底怎麼樣
上兩週
市場買盤很大
我前面講的CTA買了135個別臉
那麼這個買盤其實是
在我們在上兩週說其實已經講過
它是對於那個價格不明盤的買盤
也就是在那個時候
你不管是市場漲還是跌
它都要去跟你買的
然後這一週基本上
我們看CTA的買盤還是這個樣子
就是它不太受到市場的影響
你看一下CTA的數據
它不太受到市場的影響
那個不管你在Barecase
那個Bookcase還是Barecase
你在美國S&P的買盤
就是20個別兩百億
這個200億不是這週的數據
是這週後面四天的數據
就是我拿的這個截圖是今天早上拿的
我今天早上分析過數據了
所以是狗們昨天晚上
20號晚上出的這個報告
所以你可以看到左邊那個CTA的圖
就是它不管在什麼樣的情況下
這一週還是要給你印滿20個別臉
印滿20個別臉
然後Global要印買大概35個別臉
其實你覺得比較奇怪的就是
在Bookcase買的還沒有Flatcase多
這個我覺得沒有錯
它就是一個我們認為
就是在過去三週裡面發生的
一個叫做價格不敏感性的CTA買
那為什麼會發生這種事情呢
那跟它的這個均線計算
跟它那個長期的Trendy跟蹤
這個東西有關
所以你當你砸下去的時候
其實相當於它改變了它的Trend
那麼在改變它的趨勢
那個在這個趨勢裡面它就是全部在做空
但是當你回頭以後
它整個趨勢性的變化以後
CTA根據權重性的計算它就
它就要去買回來
特別是現在已經漲回錢高以後
它就要是買回來
你哪怕跌了它還是等於是
根據過去權重還是要把它買回來
那就是無敏感性的有200億的買本
所以其實這個回答有不少人
在問我關於CTA的事情
所以CTA是最長沙爹
那沒錯
它是最長沙爹
但它最長沙爹根據的趨勢
它並不是一天或者兩天的趨勢
它這個趨勢時間更長
所以我們回顧過去一個月的市場
之前CTA和系統性的賣盤1800億
1800億的樣子在一個月裡面賣出1800億
它砸到了6300
然後其實在6300這位置是砸不動了
如果你就從一個拉盤的角度來講
就是你市場上你自己操作拉盤角度
你拼命砸砸了1800億還是砸不動
在那個位置肯定就是階段性的底部
就是你肯定是砸不動
然後稍微一點買盤就能把它點燃
所以你就相當於是在那個時間點
我們在三周前說到過這個問題
三周前其實我好像是我推特也發過說到這個問題
就是你相當於整個市場積累了很多很多財貨
然後你去在那個點砸不動的那個點去點了一把火
那個時候不管
而且那個時候新聞面也支持
就說伊朗和美國要停戰
其實即使不停戰他一樣不反彈
因為買盤的確定性很高
然後在那個時候去點了火以後
他在上上周和上一周
其實上一周也漲了很多
那你其實S&P連續12天的12個
零件12天在漲
但是上上周和上周漲幅是上上周高
買入的量是上周多
這個就是相當於你在拉盤的時候
你一開始拉的時候
這個你放一點錢
你就可以把趨勢逆轉
然後把這個盤子拉上去
但是你拉的越高
你需要放入更多的錢
其實你需要的這個就是很多人不理解這個市場
包括樂觀情緒公司好不好
包括這個漲幅
你買多少錢都是這個道理
就是你要從就相當於是距離速度和加速度
這三個東西的關係
你的距離是好消息
你拉了多少錢
CTA多少買盤
但是你能不能拉的動是速度
就是我增量是多少
然後增量對比上
我的這個價格的漲幅是怎麼樣的
所以從這個角度來看
其實拉盤在這一周
我們說拉盤就是買了把那個市場拉上去
拉盤在這一周其實是面臨阻力的
但是它確實跌不動
它跌不動
但是它往上拉是面臨比較明確的阻力
雖然它在這個階段
你看這個我鼠標點的地方
這是有很明確的
不管多少它都會買
但是為什麼拉不動呢
因為上一周放了更多的錢漲幅在下降
這一周放的錢是少於上一周
也是少於再上周的
雖然它是有200億的確定的買盤
那個買的量是比上兩周要少
所以你相當於是第一天
你去點了財貨
然後燒的速度
在第二周是最快的
所以漲幅第二周少於第一周
在第三周現在
就是我們財貨差不多燒完了
就是如果說強勢性買盤
差不多燒完
所以這一周直接就是靠
新同性的買盤拉盤
我覺得在這一周結束了
但是接下去的時候
我們會看到的是公司要報業績
我當我講公司業績的事情
然後在整個整個
整個那個開始
就是一季度完
就是在那個伊朗問題發生和打仗的時候
這個期間SNP的收益的預期增加5%
所以最終大家不會太關心
我短期裡面打仗打成什麼樣子
油價會不會上升
然後會不會找這一次短暫性的這個通脹
或者是經濟有衰退
這個都能夠容忍
就是我的長線的story
或者中長線的story
故事有沒有被改變
這個才是現在市場上增加關係
就是我AI驅動的經濟效率的增加
然後我AI偷渴無限的需求
然後對於半導體的無限的需求
然後半導體無限需求
導致這些公司的盈利在上升
公司盈利上升
主要是存儲的公司調整
來這位就個5%
存儲的公司調整
裡面佔很大的比率
然後就是半導體的需求上升
這個東西故事在嘛
故事在
你打成沒事
你就打吧
你就打出問題
也是短期的
就是你最終會解決
所以市場現在進入這樣的一個
拖命的狀態
那麼半導體其實帶動了上一波
就是在那個底部攀升的時候
最主要就是半導體在場
我其實一直很討好半導體
因為最終你的本質是需求是無限的
現在需求幾乎需求
你可以認為它是無限
然後包括我上次也講到mithios
你可以認為
那個Andopic最好的模型
它為什麼只開放給公司
它說是因為安全原因
對吧
它怕被黑客利用安全原因
然後它的功能力太強了
這個軟件能力太強
其實我覺得一般是market
就是你其實也沒有搶到這個地
我們用下來
Corex和那個4.6沒有差太多
那是GPT和那個Andopic的模型
差沒有太多
那Andopic可能是在那個execution上
不會確實會好意
但是本質是它的算力不夠
它只能給企業端用
也就是有可能以後模型會分成
就是散戶
就老百姓你用的這個模型
你如果不付錢
你就用GNR
你全是中國的
然後你付錢你就用4.6
然後或者是用它第二代型
然後最多的算力
需求最大算力的
然後最好模型
可能是給企業端用
就是它其實本質還是一個需求
不足
那麼帶動了這個半導體的
引力帶到的半導體的需求
最後市場接著就是要看
Show me face
就是要看引力會怎麼樣
所以總統來講
Systematic Position
在這周結束
如果是在底部跟著我去做了很多
甚至有人做光管
做光管去買的話
我覺得風險在下一周開始
會開始累積
下一周是要考試
比如你考得好
考得不好
這個東西
你們要看自己判斷
在現在這個階段不好使
就是無所謂
它肯定要買
為什麼說考試了
那個市場不是一定跌
如果你回到CTA的這個倉位
你可以看
它從在下周開始
它如果不case的話
它買不了多少
因為其實已經倉位開始打足了
然後別case要賣掉很多
你看要開始賣掉很多
然後看上去好像很危險的樣子
但是你也要看的是primebook
其實現在只是貧空
就是這個是對沖基金
對沖基金就往下就是賣了
那其實你看這個26年打仗以後
它其實賣出的量是非常多的
2.5個Zisco
就2.5個Sigma以外的賣盤
賣盤很大
然後上兩周
基本上賣盤從ETF角度是頻掉
從美國ETF角度是頻掉
Global沒有頻
Global
Primebook現在基本上
還是stay on station
但是美國ETF是頻了
但它頻的是ETF
不是頻的個股
也就是說
對沖基金基本上現在處於觀望狀態
然後我把一部分倉位放在做空個股
然後用ETF做多
然後來底頻這個倉位
就是對很多表達
它對很多行業還是不太看好
那麼這些行業的業績
會不會爆發一下
然後讓它們把空頭給打頻掉呢
這個就是要
就是大家對這個業績的看法
對吧
因為這個是Hatch Fund
其實這個沒有
但是另外一個就是Long Only Book
或者是Long Show Fund
就是我的那個買
就是上班買買股票那些基金
就是折弧的
折食折弧基金
它們基本上也在觀望
就是我們會看到觀望性還是很大
就是整個市場
就是我們叫Fundamental基本盤
買入的基本盤
一方面是散戶
一方面是Systematic
就是那個CTA
然後Wall Control
這些Systematic Book
然後第三個就是基金
就是折弧的對沖基金和Long Only Book
第三者其實在第三個類型
它們其實是在整個市場上面
現在還是處於觀望狀態
所以最終你如果業績好的話
不代表市場就是一定會跌
就是這個看法
不是完全跟隨CTA的現在倉位的
就是說整個市場倉位沒有打到橫滿
如果說整個市場倉位現在打到橫滿
這樣的Systematic Book
這個樣的CTA的倉位出來
那我會覺得下周大概率要跌
就是加概率
而且要調整比較大的一段
但是現在市場並不是這樣子
所以你不能光看這個
這個不能光看
然後另外一個原因
為什麼我覺得這周
其實你不用去跨政治經文
這周政治經文對市場沒有影響
為什麼呢
因為整個Gamma Book被重新標籃
我們之前講過這個問題
就是Dilemma是當多的話
就Gamma
Portrait Gamma的時候
當市場在下跌
然後投行就會買路
然後市場在上漲
投行就會賣出
所以它是相當於是平衡市場作用
那麼一方面有比較確定的強Flow
然後像CTA200億
在這周會強行的買路
一方面有投行的Gamma重複的
就是本來是跌的時候
它會狂脈
然後漲的時候狂脈的
就是那種
但是現在Dilemma
現在恢復了很高了以後
其實你每一次
你要讓這個市場下跌
下跌的時候
你要對著CTA的買盤
同時你要對著那個投行的買盤
投行對出買盤
那這個買下去的難度蠻大的
就是有兩方面的市場
就兩方面是
但是上漲的時候
它不一定會懵懵
因為我上漲的時候
投行等於是在賣出
所以這一周
我覺得市場基本上比較溫和的上漲
或者是比較flat
這個概率是比較大
你要是只是憑談判的問題
要讓把這兩天把市場雜耗坑
不太容易
但是下一周也不一樣
下一周就是我們叫修密
修而領
然後同時的話
要修你最終會怎麼樣
市場最近會做得怎麼樣
這也就說到那個買盤買在哪裡
其實買盤買在
為什麼大盤股漲這麼多
其實就是因為我之前講的
那個買盤買在ETF上面
或者是買在3米上
買在3米和ETF上面
那ETF其實中間很大
就是大盤股就會被買了很多
包括我們看到之前講到的一些
包括軟件類的
那個微軟也反彈了不少
微軟買它都大反彈
這個就是整個市場買ETF的結果
所以買ETF的結果
那做空的一些盤
其實沒有還沒有大規模的反彈
就是你最終還是要看
後面一個基督而已
為什麼我覺得
這一基督穩定比上一基督重要
就比去年年紀重要
因為這一個基督特別多的關注力
都放在乎字幕字海峽上
和放在油價上
放在美國市場打仗上
然後承接了這個星期開始
到下星期就接下去幾個星期吧
就開始要出盈利了
然後市場並沒有給盈利主顧的關注
關注都是在打不打不仗
川普發佈發推特
川普發佈發出出中學
然後出去就講了什麼東西
然後他們談不談又談崩了
就是關注到這個東西上
但是對於盈利的關注其實沒有足夠
但是忽然之間要考試了
然後盈利會變得很重要
所以接下去這些數據就會更加驅動於盈利的這些東西
所以這個東西很重要
我待會時間如果來得及的話
我會講一講那個Intel
或者是我上次說每次可能講一公司吧
我可能會講一下CPU的公司吧
Intel AMD
MD關於GPU我們上次講過
然後我可能會講一下Intel
所以這個是後市的市場的這個情況
然後整個市場情緒
我覺得如果從短線來看
Bolish sentiment有點高
就是整個市場的樂觀情緒相對來說還是比較高
但是如果說Earning能夠維持住
因為我覺得大概率是在至少在半導體上問題不大
Earning能夠維持住的話
你可以回頭看2023年它出現SVB的問題
然後出現SVB問題後
那個Nostar指數還是漲漲至37
就是其實很多市場的衝擊
在短期的衝擊
對整個股市的影響或風險資產影響沒有那麼大
風險資產上一輪
就是從去年底到今年年初這一輪
本質被壓制是最早大家質疑頭肯的需求
這個是最重要的
就是質疑AI的需求
AI需求到底是不是真的
覺得AI需求是被CAPEX帶動
AI需求就是半導體確實CAPEX帶動
但是CAPEX帶動有沒有收益
這個問題大家一直在問
所以有沒有收益
然後有沒有收益前段
就是有沒有需求
頭肯有沒有需求
華爾街從來不相信有這個需求
那麼現在有沒有需求這件事情
正在慢慢被化解
因為當anthropic的模型
被越來越多的企業端的所有人應用的
就是其實我相信聽電話的人
幾乎每一個都應該用anthropic
再做各種各樣的變成
就是這個是正常情況
就是比較你如果沒有這麼幹的話
就有可能你這個人要被淘汰到
就是那個大概率就是大家做這個事情
所以token的需求現在慢慢被認可了
現在華爾街還沒有完全認可
包括你去看到New Cloud的這些公司
包括你看到那個All over New York公司的時候
是token需求是確定的
模型需要去調用它
但是你有沒有financial result
有沒有就是收益
你收益能夠做到的
這個是現在正常來質疑的
所以最終這一環節
我覺得大概率其實是會過掉的
因為你買卡回本就是年半
這個你算力需求很高
買卡回本一年半
它很多的CAPEX投到了那個土建上面
那玩意你要攤銷20年了
所以如果說土建的比率
土建比率下降有幾方面原因
第一個包括中國賣給它的那個交換機
都不太夠
所以有很多的那個
其實明年CAPEX再下降
所以CAPEX一下降
大家會很緊張
這半導體公司會不會有問題
其實明年會證明
CAPEX增速下降
增速下降
其實半導體公司的Earning
沒有什麼特別大的問題
因為你買卡還得繼續
你的買卡這件事情本身
是一年半到兩年回本
所以這個我覺得在未來今年
今年底
算是這個事情會慢慢消化
所以最終為什麼我去講SVB呢
就是SVB的情況
Fail市場在質疑的時候
最終只要能夠認可
你的Earning是能夠維持的
你的模式是一直是賺錢的
那麼市場普談會太轉期是會有衝擊的
但是短期這些衝擊
包括你打賬
包括你油價找200好了
你改變不了
改變不了本質
然後韓國
韓國
韓國估值比較低
就是包括三星和海利市
然後海利市在6月份上上市
所以就說如果超美光
我覺得還不如超海利市
這個就很簡單
我覺得估值比較低一點
但是你韓國還有
就是受到油價打擊比較嚴重之前
所以海利市是破性高
但是它Earning也破性高了
然後受到油價打擊了
所以美國沒有受到太大油價打擊
包括你看美光這些
它的影響
因為畢竟美國也不是缺油
我之前就講它
它是往別人毛課裡推了款式的
然後
所以如果情況會緩解
包括Show Me的Face中間
它的Earning比較好
其實可以關注一下韓國人
韓國的票
然後我覺得
我如果沒時間講英特爾的話
我就先講一下Fat
因為今天晚上Cabin Wash
要去Selator做Hillary
然後它能不能
其實中間有幾個問題
第一個它是鷹派是鴿派
大家有很多的質疑
很多的debate
很多的debate這個事情
第二個就是它能不能被任命
我上週好像已經講過關於Cabin Wash的事情
我覺得因為它的re-mark
它要去講的prepared re-mark
這個您出來看過
包括
Wall Street Journal的專訪
他寫過兩篇關於Cabin Wash的報導
我覺得這個值得大家讀一下
我覺得我比較認同它的很多觀點
簡單來說是這樣子
就是第一它會不會被任命
我覺得經過糾葛糾結
最後它會被任命
不太會因為一個DOJ的case
讓DOJ就有那個
就等於他們在調查那個
J-PAL的包圍的那個貪腐案子
然後現在那個參議院要求
你把這個案子給drop掉
把它丟掉
不要去相當於去迫害人家
然後我才能任命新的聯儲主席
我覺得最終不太會因為司法的案子
阻止Cabin Wash上來
因為Cabin其實最後還是
Trump特朗普的小弟
就是他兄弟的兒子
他是絕對是Trump鐵桿
然後他上來其實要執行很多Trump的政策
那在選擇政策能被執行
不能被執行
和要不要瑕疵
把那個J-PAL搞死
這個之間Trump習慣性的會踏口
他肯定踏口
就是他如果是
這個是一個tipping point
他肯定是踏口的
你不用去想
然後那個如果他其實
只是想賣自己競選人
資助者兄弟的一個面子
要把他女婿搞上來
然後他沒有真的想支持他的話
他也可以把這個事情拖著
所以如果開幕是爭陰派
那Trump可以脫離這件事情
不讓人上來
然後所以最終連儲是會很割的
我們看Financial FCI Index
包括Financial Condition Index
其實最近都很鬆
整個市場流動性很鬆
不光是美國
包括中國
美國在上兩周的時候
我剛剛忘記講了
我覺得可以補充一下
美國在上兩周的時候
那個Sofa Rate是低於Falcon
就低於那個連儲的Swap
所以相當於是銀行間的流動性
銀行間的利益是低於基準利率
不好
很可怕吧
就是流動性已經多到這個地步
到RRP裡面去了
然後上一周沒有這樣
然後這一周也沒有
其實這倆接下去兩周
流動性沒有那麼鬆的原因是收稅
那個稅收收了以後
錢是到了TGA
到了那個連儲的帳戶
等於是我本來人的錢
是放在銀行帳戶
對吧
然後因為收稅
我把這個錢交給國家
交給國家以後
穿稅的帳戶在美聯儲的
所以相當於是美聯儲
把那個銀行的錢給收過去了
所以這個過程
是等於是減少流動性的
整個今年流動性是很寬裕的
包括你看到這個
包括銀行的拘檢館
各方面的原因之後
一開始4月初流動性寬裕到這個地步
但是在短暫的週期
就從4月份開始
接下去
接下一個月開始
接下去可能一個月
或者幾個星期
那個時候流動性不是很寬裕
因為收稅的週期
這個是seasonal的
這是我們叫季節性的
這個沒有辦法
這是肯定會發生
所以結合前面的那個倉位的東西
你們可以考慮一下
自己倉位怎麼放
我覺得這個是可以考慮
然後我說回一下
我是它基本上還是一個隔牌
所以它會被任命
這是我的基本看法
第二就是它在被任命的時候
它講了兩個重要的講話
一個是2025年年底
它講到關於通商
它提到了
就是說是通商這個東西是在
就是它提到Greenspan
就是Greenspan在1990年的時候
1990年年初
它沒有去申席
它覺得這個是對的
因為為什麼呢
是生產力在科技下面大提高
所以這個時候
基本上是deflationary是通縮的
所以我們不需要
按照傳統的看法去申席
對抗通商這件事情
等於是對抗通商這件事情
不用急
現在整個生產力在大提高
這些人都要失業了
所有的程序
因為你看那個
TOPIO創始人講了一個
就是50%的投行資訊
然後和程序員
在未來一到五年要失業
我覺得這個太moderate了
太說太客氣了
不需要一到五年
可能一年到兩年
就給你全部幹掉
所以它覺得
因為這個原因
所以我們並不需要快速的去申席
deflationary
它更加關注
deflationary就是失業的風險
這個是2025年年底講
然後它這次的remark
講到一個東西
就是叫做inflation is a choice
然後是聯儲的選擇
就是我選擇要不要去對抗這個通商
然後我在什麼情況下是對抗通商
這個才是聯儲的獨立性
所以那個
fat independence
就是美聯儲的這個獨立性
is largely up to fat
這個是它今天在remark裡面放的
就是我來決定
我多大程度上是獨立的
怎麼獨立
然後我們聯儲
from congress
從國會獲得了這個
現在我有這個mandate
我有這個任務要去對抗通商
然後我來決定
怎麼樣去推廣通商
其實我個人感覺現在市場
我變得任務一開門
我是非常非常硬盤
但是並不是
它很有可能上來跟你講兩次些
就今年很有可能
今年再上來跟你講兩次些
這個概率還是蠻大
那麼市場對於
聯儲鷹派的這個擔心
也有可能會跑掉
所以這個是我對聯儲的一個看法
就是它會被任命
但是它其實比市場預期的更加高
現在市場對於它的定價
是鷹派定價
市場對於美國和醫療的問題的
很多鷹合的定價
是最壞情況的定價
然後現在無視隱層化的情況
不然我問你
你還怎麼提這個
但是這個
所以在中期裡面
還是非常非常好
就整個市場
我覺得從token的需求
一種半導體的二令
然後從聯儲的一個東西
都非常好
但是在下一種考試
我最後兩五分鐘
我假想英條
英條必定考不好
就是那個有很多人在說
因為其實怎麼說呢
我是最早吹捧英條的人
在身邊的朋友們都知道
然後那個也有一些可能
直到我在20塊錢的時候
都在說我們不能去買這個東西
但是現在找到70塊錢
昨天現在65萬
65、66、65到70塊錢
然後CPU的需求
最近市場討論的非常多
CPU的需求會很大
因為原來有個錯誤的人質
就是我在training的階段
我只用GPU
然後GPU和CPU是1比10
所以我們以後的數據站
都是按照GPU、CPU
1比10這樣去建
但是問題並不是這樣子
就是在training階段是沒錯
大家是要訓練出來一個模型
然後我訓練模型的時候都是用GPU
但是問題我要用模型的時候
我調用的時候
我往往不是人在調用
我是Aging在調用
比方說你用Hermis
或者你用OpenCloud在那裡調用的時候
其實是機器在調用
然後問題是
還有就是機器在調用模型
再去調用東西
然後再去用東西
這個時候
或者是在搜索信息
這個時候都是要用到CPU的
所以CPU後面是常缺貨
就是會越來越多越來越多的需求
這個需求會慢慢不指數級的上升
是隨著算力提高
和人對AI的應用越來越多
在指數級的提升
為什麼我在去年底
今年年初講到CPU會缺貨
然後會這樣的提升呢
因為我們在去年底看到
生產級的AI模型發出現
然後Ethelpecenexos電火
然後生產級的模型出現
所以真正的會能夠應用到
生產使用往常景
其實在國內很多人應用的模型
現在可能GLM差不多還可以用用
就是但是沒有可能體會沒有那麼深
但是如果是你天天在用像我這樣
我這個PPT全是Cloud寫的
然後你天天在用的時候
你就感觸會很深
就是它是生產級的使用
那麼在這種情況下
CPU的用法是很多
但是Intel有Intel和AMD同樣的問題
有兩個問題
第一個在產能上去
就是你如果說
只是data3t需要更多的卡
那麼data3t需要更多卡的時候
你需要提高你的產能
你現在用的
大家需要的可能是Intel7
它是需要更加新的芯片
這不是把老片
它要新的芯片更加好的
所以產能是一個問題
第二呢在短期裡面
短期裡面
有兩億張PC的卡出貨
對於Intel來說
但是data3t的業務佔到它只有80%
也就是我那邊的業務確實很缺貨
然後我確實麻疹更高
那裡的麻疹更高
那我的PC端的業務的麻疹沒有那麼高
但是PC端的業務被存儲給打擊了
就是存儲導致電腦變貴的
所以買的人就變少了
這個很容易理解
因為存儲那邊就直接漲價
那個為什麼CPU和GPU沒有直接漲價
因為CPU、GPU它們跟存儲
不像存儲有這個商品屬性
存儲是個特別特別有商品屬性的東西
所以它就是等於是炒油一樣的那一炒
但CPU、GPU並不是這樣的
所以存儲公司Oni正常上去
p1低了
p1低了它們就貴了
就這個概念
那麼存儲漲了導致它的PC業務
其實受到影響
現在已經把PC的線切到DataCenter了
會對它Oni有幫助的
但是並不是大家預期的暴炸式的幫助
也就是它在明年年底
隨著CPU的需求
隨著它的Foundry能夠實現
隨著它packaging這些東西
真的開始見到Oni
它就應該是100塊錢
很正常
但是現在漲了其實發現很過分
就是它的Oni其實不一定支持
但是問題這個中間要看
就是它雖然考試考不好
但是大家本質上也不一定
對它考試成績包有很大的幻想
也就是說這個傢伙很聰明
然後家裡很好
然後出很多錢給它補課
它肯定會好
但是這次考試大概考不好
沒關係
市場很有可能也會這個樣子
這個也是這種概念
但是我只是很穩定了
很簡單的來說
就是它這次考試肯定考不好
還有它的同學AMB都考不好
這個大概
但是這兩個都有可能會獲得
在算力需求爆棚式增加的時候
它們都是相對來說比英偉大
英偉大做集合
叫Racking集合
它肯定是最中心的
相對於英偉大是過去蘋果的地位
那最中心
它們是稍微邊緣一點
因為算力需求太大
所以邊緣一點的都會火力
整個半導體上也都是這個樣子
所以勞倫比較不
然後在就是英偉星期四要出門裏
我星期四出門裏之前
我跟你們說一下
就是我個人為什麼對這東西的看法
相對來說沒有那麼的樂觀
我只是說這次
但是三季度四季度可能會
三季度四季度
特別是三季度四季度的後面的展望
可能會變好
就是更加變好一點
然後從那個從利普壇和
就是那個陳立五
從陳立五自己個人角度來講也是
就是我接牌年多
我肯定是先把所有責任掛在拍的多久
我們接牌公司都是這樣
老闆這都當老闆
然後接牌公司的時候
你肯定把老業務全部是以前人做
所以老業務土乾淨
基本上在這個季度下季度土乾淨
接下去全是我幹的
我就把這個業務做好了
所以時間上是這樣
然後如果說是向一條有回調的機會
我還是對這個東西的看法幫我講
到明年第一百塊錢是比較
比較比較廢的
好
那我今天要不今天先這樣
我看時間差不多
我們今天先聊到這兩吧
好
謝謝大家